am i getting punked uh claire
i think we should be the ones asking you
that question
i don't know here's what you need to
know on sunday eagle-eyed bachelorette
fans went
wild over a tweet that was liked by
claire's account
possibly hinting that she may not be the
bachelorette anymore
this is insane the tweet in question
this one
it's a gif of bachelor alum tasha adams
from colton underwood season
and it says buckle up it's getting crazy
the account that tweeted it
added the commentary i'm sure many would
be thrilled with tasia too
meaning thrilled to have tasia as our
new bachelorette
instead of claire i signed up for it for
what is it four times exactly
what's one more time the tweet got some
love from claire's account on sunday but
it's worth noting that as of monday
claire's account has since unliked the
tweet ah
the mystery continues it's a dramatic
bachelor season
like no other of course the like tweet
could mean nothing at all
while it's typical that leads don't have
their cell phones while filming we all
know ben higgins found a way around that
one
so i was in portland oregon on uh lauren
bushnell's hometown day
and we hadn't been a hotel where next to
the bed the only way to operate the room
was an ipad
and i was able to get on the internet
and look up my final three people all of
them
you know were great on instagram great
on social media there was no drama or
anything
but it did affect the way like i viewed
them afterwards
because i knew more about them as for
clair season of the bachelorette it
certainly had its fair share of ups and
downs
and guys we haven't even seen a single
episode yet
production was supposed to start earlier
this year but was delayed by the
coronavirus pandemic
as a result the show is filming on
location in palm springs
right now we're just waiting and seeing
until we can do it safely until we can
do it the right way
and despite claire patiently waiting in
quarantine to finally get her chance at
love
the cast was shaken up during the
holding period with some of her guys
replaced in july abc announced the 42
guys possibly vying for claire's park
25 are new names 17 stayed from the
original contestant pool
and 15 were cut including matt james
who was announced as the new bachelor in
june he told et
this back when he thought he was
competing for claire i hope things work
out with you and claire but if not
matt for bachelor now i hope it works
out with her too so hopefully we'll have
to get to that point but would you say
no to it
well hopefully we won't get there i
hopefully i'll be with claire but let's
go back to tasia for a moment
i'm open to anything et spoke with the
29 year old in february
just days before claire was announced as
the new season lead
and said she'd love to get the gig
telling e.t quote
i have to say anything that comes my way
i am ready for
i am ready for love i'm ready for my
next
fun adventure in that aspect as far as
reality tv i am open to the idea
i don't know i think i'm open to any
possibility of being on any show